this podcast is brought to you by our
supporters on patreon they also got this
episode ad free early and with less
editing thanks to patreon we will also
be creating another idiots and a broad
vlog which will be available exclusively
on patreon this month so please if you
want to support the show and get extra
content go to patreon.com
huge thank you to everybody who is
already supporting the show if i were to
[ __ ] anyone mr frodo
it would have been her
would have been her it would have been
her it would have been her
even with joking it makes me go to cry
so sad it is truly sad
and what about very old friends
they have they have no other master
that's my favorite secret
that's the
best you keep your secrets
it's the face he does afterwards this
little
all right then
keep your secrets the salted
consciousness is particularly good
now that's out of the way hello everyone
welcome to idiots and abroad i'm alana
that's rahul that's jacob that's john
but it's filming from jacob's
perspective so that'll probably all be
off john it is why do you look like uh
but tomato you don't think i miss your
uncle bilbo's birthday
i'm all burned up when i just i went to
the rent fair over the weekend
oh my god that was so red
[ __ ] lobster
i said i'm gonna i'm gonna
uh
hold on
oh my god stroke i i said i'm gonna buy
a hat when i get there like a medieval
hat and then all of the hats were
artisan hats that were like two hundred
and fifty dollars for some shaped
leather oh yeah oh my god everything's
created these are the worst
why didn't you get yourself a hat
like you go where you go you go wearing
look at his cruel hat you could have
borrowed his hat bear john you gotta
wear an app
i go where i at
you can you can borrow a bear's hat and
he can borrow your pants
this is uh backhand uh
oh
this camera is more for my own purposes
so that i can monitor him appropriately
than it is
you have to like look over a monitor
otherwise i think he's going to be a
famous you
yeah look at this follower
me and him watched uh instagram for him
yet honestly
hey bear what's up
poor guy we woke up this morning and we
watched it because i've been dog sitting
we uh we watched the everton game and he
fully was watching
wow he was on drugs or the drugs for
whatever but he was watching so he has
the team yeah whenever your team got
close to the basket
he'd stand up on his hind legs i'm gonna
ignore the basket just like a
basket
who didn't even register to me
it's a giant basket
it's just well it's a large i
fundamentally disagree it is just
shaped basket
yeah um john how is the wren fair
it was okay there were so many people
there that i we couldn't even get drunk
jacob and i were there yeah john smith
yes what was the um
racial di uh ratio of the crowd at the
wren fair what would you say oh it was
whites only except jacob who no i snuck
in in full armor it was 99 yeah
no they were turning people away at the
door it was yeah
very popular well john and i came in as
a single centaur he was the front
and i was the back
that's why you're not sunburned
oh that's the worst yeah the backs of
the knees because every time you walk it
hurts i don't know about sunburn this is
conversation excludes me
i've seen you sunburned before when i
was in high school i was outside like
every day running like for four hours
every afternoon yeah
you did uh
uh what are they called like cross
country that's it that's how you got
those games
he does have beautiful
sticks his getaway sticks my pillars
gorgeous gorgeous
um so all i got so far was that it was
hot the hats were expensive and it was
busy is that the official idiots in a
broad review of friends
it's very basically yeah this is why
people come to our travel podcast yeah i
assume people go to rent fairs to hook
up
really think so is that not a thing i
assume people go there oh
john what are you going to have sex in a
porta potty when you meet someone
i've never been but i assumed that they
were titties
touching people's chins oh dude it was
ridiculous
there were so many corsets
where it wasn't even like
how do you know why we look at it it was
like it was like they were on a platter
yeah
like that's how forced up they were
interesting context that's actually
quite comfortable like boobs going up
they know what they're doing they
they know what they're doing how many
ways being era appropriate
every event
the lady had like a carrot sticking out
of her boobs
oh yeah that was the thing
everybody had something in their boobs
this i maintained i'm so out of it
for people to [ __ ] i think all of my
energy is going to my forehead
your body's trying to go make yourself
do that thing again with the veins now
i don't even remember what you're
talking about i do want to say you look
you actually look less red on camera
than you do in person yeah yes oh god
yeah
yep i look like a lobster
i'm still fishing for more ran for rent
fair review other than of course
oh my god it was crazy okay well it was
like we were
we were walking
on our we were on our way out crazy
and there was this guy i saw him in his
shirt i was like is that the pornhub
logo but no it said park
or
so it was parkour but it was
the pornhub logo genius that's clever
didn't funhouse do that once
indeed
i never where
um
but then someone else behind us went
parkour
and and they both
like did
oh they didn't flip or anything no there
was nothing it was too hot
so
we'll add that to the wren fair review
yeah yeah no flips
expensive hats hot
whites only yeah how many how many of uh
how many red fairs had you been to how
which one was this i've only been to one
before and it was the best day of my
life yeah this is my first one
i've also only been with one we're in
fed um yeah in australia and i assume
that la one's a bit different do they
have jousting and [ __ ] there was a
japanese yeah
oh i was rooting for maximilian the
black and yellow knight oh nice oh he
was oh man he was so [ __ ] hot
he looked like jacob we realized that
like a third of the way through the
joust that jacob was cheering for
maximilian and maximilian
looked like his uncle mm-hmm so wait
it is does that make jacob our resident
himba
yes to bimbo but it's him i don't know
how many do you think jacob's also a man
of color you don't get to play that card
jacob don't count i've taken away his
man of color card what no i need that
i could make certain jokes
you're obsessed with lord of the rings
you went to hobbiton
also showing me a video
of a miniature painter that was painting
the sharding when he looked me went
i went there
also i have been planning this trip for
the four of us and probably also terror
realistically um to go to a full like
proper stay in ranch where we would like
go horse riding and stuff and rahul is
very excited about it is that people of
color [ __ ] rahul
yeah uh natives
but you're not native
no you're not even from here where are
you from but but but but you know you
told me one time that was writing is
white people [ __ ] and i told autumn that
you said that and she was like oh he's
right
it you know it is it is but i'm doing it
the people are colorway
okay
okay
how's that dingling off the side
no um no uh helmet and no um
seat
you can tell i've been watching all
right
no saddle
no handlebars no handlebars no seat
no ac no wing mirrors
just bare back
got it my bullet is in the back of the
door and i hate that it's barefoot it's
quite difficult to get on actually
i'm gonna be naked too
well well so
uh yeah i want to i wanted to i think i
brought it up to to lana
that like
you know i was zoned out for like
20 seconds
we got bear to in back up that's who
your replacement is he's right there
we'll tag him in yeah um yeah i i i
don't really suggest many things for
this podcast um
really or anything and i don't do any
travel and i don't want to travel
but i
i asked alana and i said hey
can we figure out like somewhere we can
go wild westy
um and like vlog it or something and
lana found this ranch that does
yeah we're gonna do it we'll vlog it
it'll be awesome also for everybody
who's been asking um the
erased episode i'll have up in probably
like two weeks i think
well no
no that's not quite close but that'll be
12.
the sunburn yeah
i really got it faster sorry i already
have my outfit picked for our travel is
that exactly what you're wearing right
now
yes this is a replica our audio
listeners this is
a
very high quality
replica of clint eastwood's poncho from
the sergio leone spaghetti westerns um
i'm also every now and again holding a
cult 45
um
i hope i don't get swatted because i
will get shot if they
because there's no way i could let it go
you're gonna be like
it's a time
no it's s off [ __ ]
um but what's missing from my outfit is
uh the hat which i'm trying to get
before the ranch and me and john we was
chilling on the couch the other day and
we were watching fistful of dollars and
we got a bit hyper and i bought
50 of clint's stubby cigars
um but you can't get them because they
won't verify your age they won't verify
that i'm not i'm older than 21 and i
missed the delivery because the dh
the ups guy needed to visually id me to
give me my cigars
is that profiling
probably yeah again jacob are you
building gundam right now
no you son of a [ __ ]
it's like i was on autopilot i didn't
even realize i was doing it and now a
very important message from our sponsors
oh my god so many things are popping
hey y'all how's it going
we're here to talk to you about this
thing that i had to look up on google
called patreon patreon patreon patreon
now you may know that uh we talked about
some crazy
dirty
uh like moist uh
stuff
on this podcast indeed yeah a lot of our
youtube podcasts have been monetized oh
yeah yeah so the only way that
uh we can survive as a podcast
is
desperately through your help on patreon
do we get money from you
from patreon yeah yeah yeah so i buy
[ __ ]
yeah for the for the podcast oh i don't
give a [ __ ] about that
we're gonna like take
trips uh and that's all gonna be funded
by that i make a vlog
every now and then
and that's gonna be on the patreon
jacob's butthole
if you're lucky is on the patreon right
now
[Music]
we'll put up also those unannounced
shows yeah why not just put it out there
all right so that's what you'll get on
patreon
uh
vlogs early access to uh maybe yeah to
shows that aren't out yet and jacob's
butthole
mwah anyway we go to uh
see you later
this will make alana happy
this codex
favorite book alana's favorites are
blood angels i love a blood angel i've
been reading blood angel books since i
was like 13. have you really
yeah
you know you went into a world oh my god
they were very rude
to it
shut your mouth i literally got you in
the war hammer i think i probably would
have um
painted warhammer but when i first went
in as a young girl they were not nice to
me at all
um
and so i just bought some books and left
that's really sad isn't it unfortunate
yeah because i probably would have done
it it's because they had a crush on you
because if i had
like it would break my heart if i like
if i were everyone's meeting you john
yeah if i had a daughter right like
i i would love
her to like have the same hobbies i have
or at least try them and stuff like that
and if i took it to like a games
workshop already took it to him and and
then she got that it would break my
[ __ ] heart [ __ ] get killed
yeah you'd break their [ __ ] throats
with your airsoft mm-hmm i would love to
see rahul punch children
and the women and children i'm a big
softie and uh john's realized i'm all
talk which i think everyone suspected
them will talk after how i've been with
the dog
john cena well here's the thing i wasn't
even thinking about it i was just like
oh rojo's taking care of a dog but
multiple times a day rahul would be
doing something and he'd stop and you go
don't tell anyone about this
[Music]
he thinks he has a bad boy image for
some reason
it's because i'm uh it's because i have
robert pattinson batman hair
and that just screams
edgy
yeah do you have a robert pattinson
batman back he had a good back he did
got good backs
yeah how did he do that he made his back
all like back he was pushing that table
i was like
the batman i'm more down the clown nice
um jacob can you because john uh we
should i think just assume is written
off
from heatstroke um
can we get any more info about what
happened for hot night
i mean yeah there was a lot of waiting
in lines it was warm but we had it was a
good group we were running with
uh
like i mean that's the thing it really
was it was mostly waiting in lines yeah
well like the the meat that they had was
like canned meat it was only like four
percent alcohol so i gave up on it
pretty quick what was the jacob what was
the what was the clunge situation like
um
less clunge than tit
uh
gash
yeah
this is technically just pejorative for
women in general but i like that jacob
assumed that you meant literally which i
wanted to get specific jacob we just
watched in betweeners
a few days ago and i thought you'd
picked up the uh the lingo i mean i've
been saying it too much at home already
so i'm trying to tarot yeah i keep
saying clunge gash
oh it's terrible um but i love it
well a lot of the time
we were basically babysitting uh ryan
haley in a dragon costume
oh my god oh okay the funniest you guys
know how kids because you know they're
sensory overload they can't pay
attention to brian haley they'll have
[ __ ] all over their face and they won't
know it
yeah that was ryan ryan's face was
covered in like turkey grease he had a
turkey leg
yeah he had a turkey leg
and he was just like
ah i'm rygar and he was yelling at
everyone
what was that that makes sense did that
all day all of it
what was the food like
it was good was it like classic i'm
picturing like a game of thrones buffet
or something like that or like oh i wish
jacob and i got uh
got a uh what was it pastrami sandwich
yeah which you know sounds good
sandwich and then jacob said i want the
pastrami and i was like i could dig it
yeah
and then they the lady said do you want
cheese and chicken was like of course we
want cheese yeah and what she meant was
a giant ladle full of nacho cheese was
poured on top
not like drowning everything out
i'm picturing like you know like a pig
or a boar on a on a
spit with a out or an apple when you
know what i mean and like i had a legs
of turkey
with a big brick of cheese and a sausage
on it that was exciting
did people talk in an english accent
oh yeah
did they what the the the star for
anyone like where they're like welcome
here oh yeah they all they all mom's a
[ __ ]
here's the thing all the people
understand hired to do it it makes sense
then there's other people that go
specifically so they can role play as
those right in that time which is old it
used to be that's why i think the renfre
needs to be gate kept the renfre used to
be fenerbahce confusing larping
no that's true and now
i think it's a place that jocks go to
[ __ ]
such as jacob
especially jacob why because they that's
why they went the fool and they win the
maiden
yeah
did were there a lot of kids there did
kids go even though they were cool
there's vendors there were hat vendors
people selling crystals people selling
salt what
people selling absinthe
oh there was a lady with a hurdy gertie
and tara said can you play us a song and
she said no and then she turned and
walked away oh i love a hoodie goodie
what a
great instrument
hell yeah yeah she had never seen two so
the the official idiots in a broad
review of the renfer is middling
i want to go again
wait like 10 years and then go when it's
died down and not a lot of people are
going to it anymore i had overheard
somebody in line when i was waiting to
get food um
the guy behind us like yeah like i went
last time before the pandemic and like
this is like twice as many people as
there usually is
so i think it's just like a rush to go
back and enjoy a renaissance fair
experience
poor puppy yeah look at their face this
is this is the drugs have kicked in so
he's just staring at me
but he doesn't know what to do with the
stan there's the temper the first day he
was back he was so drugged out he like
looked up at me and his eyes were going
in two directions he has a lazy eye
anyway oh okay yeah and one of my
favorite features of his is his
ongoing
lazy eye
he looks like a fish he's a good boy
yeah they had a turtle race um well
that's cool yeah and uh
i think ryan was the only one who put
money on it did he wait um he gave some
extra money to the lady running it so
she told him which was which one was
winning
she bribed
but it was so funny because they lift up
the little like it's like a planter pot
like that they lift up and all the
turtles are underneath and she'll lift
it up and like two of them take off
and then the rest are just like
just not moving at all just don't
understand the concept of a race they
don't they just want to get the [ __ ]
away from everybody screaming at them no
listen the rin fare was fine but it
paled in comparison to my birthday party
oh
oh i've been out of town thursday was
your birthday party well that was it we
specifically threw it when you were out
of town
jacob and rahul came over
and then we
i'm a boy
and well adam didn't participate he did
rahul's friend adam was also present
shout out
all at once later shout out to adam
fosulo
oh uh no he said he liked it he said you
liked it he didn't like the sausage
fingers oh yeah those were bad he
thought it kept coming back too many
times to sausage hands
specifically that makes sense
what are you talking about the
hot dog fingers
jacob came over yeah yes
we both busted out gundams
rahul busted out
paints
and ball bearings and bald oh my god
that's what i was doing yeah
[ __ ] i thought i was painting you're
right it was the ball bearings you were
like three hours
was putting little metal balls in his
paints and then shaking them and
listening to them
well yeah scale 75 paints for anyone
who's a
miniature painter scale 75 i like their
paints but
they come out [ __ ] terrible you they
need a really good shake and i i have a
thing here that shakes test tubes that i
put
but uh because i was painting at alana's
i decided to buy a hundred pack of ball
bearings so i sat there while they were
having gundam and chatting unscrewing
each one putting a ball bearing and it
took me [ __ ] ages to do their entire
yeah we were watching like charles
counter attack and you're sitting on the
floor just like
um
oh no but actually
john
uh you'll remember that the night before
we started your birthday celebrations a
little earlier
we did but it was
after the 420 stream we did at funhouse
and i barely remember anything that we
did there i videoed it i got you a cake
from the milk barge remember
yeah i came in with it it was just me
and john i came into the to the uh
living room with a birthday cake and we
had um what the [ __ ] did we eat for your
birthday
hot chicken yeah i think you had 24 hot
no we had yeah we had dave's dave's days
we had dave's and then we did a cake and
then john went to bed at like eight and
then yeah because he was [ __ ] and i
slept for 12 hours how'd the 420 stream
go
i don't know
i walked in no the weed makes you
forgetful
i have a bad brain anyways but we does
sometimes affect short-term memory
i came in um because i was shooting
some other things while that stream was
going on and i walked into the control
room as it was ending and the only one
who was like really on and doing stuff
was ryan
and everybody else was just like
chilling
but i think it's because ryan had been
high all day yeah but he's also always
high yeah yeah that's true
like for him it's just a regular old day
yeah
yeah i didn't know weed makes you forget
stuff i know it makes people like sleepy
and zoned out i didn't know what made
you yeah
that's right that you're straight edge
that's that's me straight edge's book i
forgot that i ate a bunch of gummies
before going to hang out with john and
rahul and i was already called out for
looking sleepy-eyed oh dude your eyes
were
it's the funniest thing though they were
almost drinks yeah
i don't know how yeah i don't know how
you saw charles counter attack and built
a gundam like that
i did i barely did both
well i uh i don't know which one of you
it was but i uh cleaned up the i was
cleaning up afterwards just like after
bear and dog hair and stuff and i found
it felt like it was a really important
gundam piece under the couch
it was the face right yeah it was the
joy i thought it might have been
so someone one of you like clipped the
drawer it was my job and i thank you for
finding it oh good okay yeah i put it
back in the box faceless condom
useless
uh we did go uh jacob and i to gundam
pop-up store in little tokyo right
with lawrence and steph
that was super fun i'd actually never
been to little tokyo before um yeah
that's right
uh
i didn't like that there was a full
store full of merch that calls it
japanjulies
they just wasn't there in japan and los
angeles and it's it's just japanjulies
just wasn't a fan of that i love that
that's amazing what about the store full
of funko pops so full of funko pops that
i was like oh i love collectibles walked
in and saw them and turned away it was
like
never it's literally only funko pop yes
well it's frustrating it's all tokyo
jungle it's all the same store in three
different like rooms and one of them
everyone else went out of business
yeah they just took over the whole area
but yeah the pop-up was cool it was
really cool yeah they had all these um
like translucent gundams yeah it's a lot
of limited
very cool ones and then there was this
batman there that i'm gonna buy when it
comes out that wasn't available at the
time yeah so funko batman
not a funko batman thank you god um
and yeah walked around we bought i
bought a magikarp that i'm going to
build at some point
right
yeah i think it's bandai big old
magikarp bought a bunch of like pokemon
t-shirts it's also just weird being in
little tokyo because
the volume of us as a collective being
recognized in that specific area is much
higher than your average l.a because of
the volume of nerds is so high
you say that though you say that though
piss um
during the week
uh i
took a trip to
um this [ __ ] awesome place uh
warhammer cafe
uh it's in monto montoya monte mondo
moldova i don't know something
yup that's it
it's uh i highly recommend it since we
are a travel show
um if alana can remember oh i'll google
it so i'll get the right place but um
yeah so i took a drive there
and it's a beautiful store that has
warhammer themed
coffees and pastries and stuff like that
um
you can get a non-oil
uh coffee that's actually pretty sick um
but yes
coffee
what's that
anonymous coffee that's what it's called
it's just probably your coffee
interesting but i went i went down there
uh picked up some paints and picked up
some more um
um a combat patrol box but but but um
yeah it's a really nice space i highly
recommend going i'm gonna go back
uh and
i was in there they've got like
tables to play on plus they got a really
nice store plus they got the coffee shop
but not a single [ __ ] recognized me
and that was nerdy
did you [ __ ] storm out of there i
brought up my own credits to see if it
would jog anyone's memory and it didn't
like when you did in boulder like like
the like the vampire thing where you're
like oh i should probably get a vampire
no that was john yeah no that was not
lana don't throw me under the bus who
was that
i don't know
[ __ ] off i remember john did that i uh
but the thing is you can always trust me
i'll tell you why they don't know who to
trust i'll tell you why let me tell you
why i'm more i'm more trustworthy
because i just [ __ ] admitted off my
own volition that i tried to get
recognized there so why wouldn't i admit
that's a good point i'm not embarrassed
by it so yeah john john did that at the
board yeah so i don't understand why
you're embarrassed by the one that
happened in boulder
that was the woman that you guys
couldn't get away from right no john did
that
and i remember the funniest thing about
that entire interaction was that she
really didn't want to engage
and then but then engaged in the most
long-winded way and it was like i you
don't even want to do this love
like but um
speaking of warhammer
um
oh this doesn't really concern jacob or
john but um i'll hear it out
uh there is
there is a warhammer
uh tournament the us tournament
it's called the us open or some [ __ ] uh
in san diego in
june
yep yes please june
um
and um
we will
uh me and alana are heading down there
because zlana is a warhammer fan thanks
um so we're heading over there and we
have um
we're gonna go uh they've got some paint
classes ooh
like actual
tuition classes that you can you can
attend and stuff so we're gonna watch
the battles
who's going to go to school
i don't know if i ilana can watch the
battles i told rahul that um just
because i think it's funny gonna wear to
this painting class the [ __ ] outfit
possible
because i think that the image of me
looking like i'm dressed going to a
nightclub
in in the middle of a bunch of nerds
painting warhammer at a moment
well i'm gonna regret that you're gonna
it's gonna you know what's gonna you
know what's gonna hurt you you know
what's gonna hurt you you know what's
going to hurt your ego
none of us are going to care while we're
doing xenothor highlights and um glazing
and um
non-metallic metal just look how high
this dog looks right now looks like just
all
okay but you you i mean you wouldn't do
it with spray paint you'd
i guess i got i got you i got it
you put it on a person who's ripped but
is your size yeah where is like say
they're in excel and they're ripped and
they've got abs and ting and then use
xenothor highlight them from the top so
it always looks like you have muscle
shading
i like the sound of this that's like
when you put a foundation on your boobs
people do that well a lot of
specifically maybe it's not foundation
whatever blush or whatever yeah you can
blush your chest
i think they powder it no i think it's
to take the shine on my shoulders and on
my chest before
just because it makes you look a little
bit more tan and it's pretty but i've
never done it for cleavage
listen i've got miles of it every single
way people are just drawing lines and
you're just yeah
falling right before it so wait you want
red boobs is that what the point is
no i think he's saying that they people
use makeup to
add cleavage and i don't you take that b
to a c
you know what i'm saying high five well
i wonder if you could i'm curious you
could technically go high-five him
but that's
[Music]
i have some travel news
okay
oh
yeah go ahead
um
i did a movie which i've spoken about i
think a couple of times on the podcast
uh the one that we did like in tucumcari
and drove across and all of that
what yeah i'm talking to the dog oh i
thought we lost audio
um and um it got officially selected for
the tribeca film festival
that's awesome um so i'm for the first
time i'll be flying to um
new york new york new york i'll actually
be in new york when this publishes which
is much less cool
rebecca in new york
it is yeah yeah it's a de niro's
festival
yeah i believe
started tribeca well trebek is an area
that he's invested heavily in a malcolm
was telling me about it because
malcolm's always from brooklyn and he
was telling me the history of the area
but
it's like it's become a very artsy artsy
part of manhattan the artsy part and de
niro i think specifically i think he
grew up there is an affinity for that
place and he's actually invested imagine
growing up in manhattan no
what a like
wait is it in manhattan yeah i think
tribeca is a part of manhattan um yeah
i'm pretty sure um because like this the
city i grew up in okay i had the great
barrier reef that's a pretty huge
privilege but what jacob what's
happening to your face oh sorry de niro
face
[Laughter]
that's good um you're talking to me like
the city i grew up in had so many like
big schools
and like
i don't know hey did you say something
i didn't your head john it's getting
redder john stop oh no no no
you're gonna get heat stroke inside the
house
um
i just came back from boston which is
why
everybody's been dog sitting
my dog in
he's a foster for context for everyone
who does not know bear affectionately
referred to as banjo which is the name
that i've given him uh his name is bear
um he's a foster he just had hip
replacement surgery which is why he is
as the kids would say zooted
phrase i'd never heard before until i
posted a picture of him looking hi as
[ __ ] and everybody said man's is zooted
yeah that's a uk thing where you say
zoot for a spliff
that's what you used to certainly hide
he's got to wear his dumb cone for two
weeks so that he doesn't attack his
stitches which she's trying to do anyway
um you got that naked butt i guess
what i heard licking and i was like
and i got up and he was looking like his
foot
you tricking me yeah cause cause lana
was
in boston when bear was
out of surgery
um
i went to pick him up
and it was heartbreaking like you don't
know what to expect right so i go there
and then like they bring him out on a
leash and it's just like
shaved down the side he's got shaved
over here from the you know ice bath iv
and then the [ __ ] cone
and they also took out a swollen
yeah yeah he had a growth here yeah and
he's just when he sees me a week after
we
like after i got him so i've had his
foster dog for a week and he was really
tough the first week because he's not
allowed to move too much before his hip
surgery he's now a lot easier because
he's on drugs so he's just chilling yeah
but we got to make sure he doesn't he's
going to stay chill keep him drunk but i
just like i
i um so they gave me all the information
i took the medication and um i drive a
mustang
and
it's the most like
it's not a small inconvenient car but
when you have sick dog
like it's a pain in the ass with the
bucket seats and [ __ ] so i i i couldn't
get bare into the car i had this ramp
that they gave me and he wouldn't [ __ ]
with the ramp at all
so i ended up just picking him up as
carefully as i could and i placed him in
the seat
and then i said i i i hit a lot of
traffic so we ended up being in that car
for like 40 minutes
and my heart was breaking just seeing
him like
just it's clearly in discomfort he's
currently trying so hard to chew on his
rope but he can't get it
look at his eyes
i love like all black animals because
all you can see is their eyes moving
yeah he's actually got like a lot of
orange on him he just gave up and then
laid on it it's so sad
um sweet little boy now he's doing
pretty well i think he'll be all right
he's he's you know he's still really
happy which is the main thing it's like
he's still clearly very happy wags his
tail all the time he's starting to bark
at us which is super cute
he's doing all right but yeah i went to
boston for pax east which is super fun
and the most boston experience i had
while i was there was like i went up to
some guy who i don't know it was like
security near the convention center
and i was like hey i'm trying to walk
here what's the easiest way to get there
and he was like oh that's pretty far
that's a far walk i don't know you you
want to walk that far and it was 15
minutes
and so i went and it was it was fine he
gave me the directions and i went it was
great and then when i came back he was
like long walk huh and i was like
yeah like i don't really
know what concept you have it was okay
it was like maybe 20 minutes maximum he
was like
you're going to be operating on that one
we'll walk that long
and then uh yeah when i checked into the
hotel uh because i didn't get until i
think my flight landed at 11 30 p.m
so i got in super late
and then when i got to the hotel heard
the boston accent from the people at the
check-in desk immediately as well and i
just like i had to not laugh
and it's funny because that's the accent
people think i have the most often if
i'm in a taxi that people be like you're
from boston because of car and
wheels of pronunciation of odds i need a
quarter for my daughter to buy some
water for the dagger exactly
get a quarter
dagwood
um but yes i i got in 11 30 and then had
to wake up at
what would have been like five or some
[ __ ] to do
the keynote for pax and then had to go
back to the hotel room to do my like
regular work day
on la time and that just led to me
inevitably getting a migraine and
vomiting like four times in the hotel
room
yeah i know that it i get them from
weird sleep schedules and that's like a
thing that i know but sometimes it's
very difficult to avoid
you can't really do anything about it
but i have this like prepared
thing that i eat lay's chips a banana
helps a friend of mine dropped off
coffee and excedrin
which works
i eat those two things that john is
holding
um
exactly i wanted to apologize to the
city of uh boston in general because
i've been to pax east a whole bunch and
every single time it was snowing one
time it was a blizzard and i got stuck
and something about the snow in a city
like boston or new york
when it's been there for a few days it
ends up just covered in dirt so the
roads just look like [ __ ] and then
people like drop stuff in them so
they're just dirty and they kind of
smell oh yeah no snow in boston this
time of year or not this year at least
it was beautiful like it was i was like
damn bless you climate change
thank you america god bless um no it was
gorgeous like walking around there it
was so clean like lots of very cool
cafes uh cool
nightlife
vibes everything does close pretty early
though though but um yeah boston's dope
i like it there a lot it's really cool
it's a nice you have some chatter
i did not have any chatter i have a
bread bowl
i don't know what that was
but no idea
nope
uh
when i looked at like postmates it was
just a lot of dinah food
there was a lot of a lot of diner food
and like a lot of like kebabs
came up
and i was at seaport which means i would
have thought it was seafood but not so
much and then i told my dad about boston
and i guess he looked it up for the
first time in his
beautiful sheltered life and was like oh
it's really old
it looks cool it's really old there's
like you're not wrong oh my god
it gets in america yes it's [ __ ] way
older than australia he's trying so hard
to get this rope
home i just remembered he's got a
strength i remember something else from
the ren fair oh go ahead
so the morning of the rinfer
i got up
i got ready i took a shower
got all my clothes and everything i
brushed my teeth i go downstairs and as
i'm going down the stairs i just
what's that smell it's [ __ ]
and i open the door and rahul is
sleeping there because he for the first
couple days he slept downstairs with a
dog you didn't leave the dog's side for
more than like
a couple minutes at a time ruffle
um
but uh i get down and i smell [ __ ] and i
look over
and there's [ __ ] everywhere
um
and so i go row
row
and you kind of you lose everyone i go
there's [ __ ] everywhere
what
i'm going to the rinfer see you later
that was a real dick move of you john
you didn't help at all
we had a time wow i was running i was
like i gotta get there so that we can
leave and go and i would have been
furious if john was late
yeah
i actually came downstairs in my house
because john got there before i was
ready and john was just playing elden
ring
you could have been cleaning up dog [ __ ]
i could have been i didn't even think
about helping until i was like halfway
to jacobs and i was like
i should probably
it was a strict timetable strict time
table jacob really keeps it strict no
jacob there's this thing that you do
that i always do to be clear where
you'll say leaving now and i know that
that means that you're not leaving for
another 15 minutes and i love it because
it makes it started yes i have 20
minutes
whenever jacob says leaving now i'm like
that's at least half an hour it's fine
great
it means my brain is getting ready
put on some shoes yeah i'm still leaving
now before brushing my teeth and putting
my shoes on which does add an extra tent
and i recognize that that's wrong but i
agree it's my brain saying i'm leaving
the leaving process has begun getting
out the door yep
rob experienced me uh my normal morning
process which is that i leave and come
back in four separate times because i
forget four different items you are a
forgetful man
that's true i have fish brain
you do have fish brain how did that
happen
i think it maybe it's my meds or
um something's my brain is melting oh
climate change
uh climate change just to finish off my
anecdote
how far away did we get
it was
i was just waiting uh
i basically was when i was driving bare
after all that care and attention yes i
was petting him with one hand and i was
looking at him and i looked back at the
traffic and i had to stop suddenly
and i did and he [ __ ] flew off the
bucket seat and got wedged down
into the [ __ ] bat and i was like
after all of the things they said about
don't he can't jump into stairs with the
thing and i just like made him he just
went
straight down the [ __ ] side but in
theory that wouldn't have hurt his hip
no i i i know i just it just was cracked
his skull open yeah which i just gave
him a lazy eye
he's always had that yeah yeah i felt
like i felt [ __ ] terrible
sorry for interrupting rahul apologies
i'm sure how was the cleaning up the dog
[ __ ]
it was a highlight of my year yeah
that's good um
i as john has seen
i think you've seen this too i wretch
with dog poo i just wretch in general i
have a really like sensitive
gag referee sounds about white
yeah so i think john saw
john saw me once just going
and crying over like the smallest dog
[ __ ] and smell that hit me if it hits me
too early in the morning and that that's
i think john you left at what eight in
the morning
yeah yeah it was about eight
and i what what upset me the most was i
didn't realize like the stench
was so bad because it was just contained
hot she does have stinky [ __ ] well yeah
but it's also it's a hot saturday
morning like john's burnt so when i get
downstairs raw who's going
yeah so i slept in that smell for how
the reason i was you inhaled particles
yeah pretty much but i was i was guided
like john said i i slept with with dog
downstairs so i just slept on the couch
and
um
that night in particular i remember
like at one in the morning i went over
and um
jacob we [ __ ] see what you're doing
bro
i'm just jacking off
[Laughter]
uh
yeah i i remember having to check on him
because i thought he was breathing too
heavy and then at five in the morning he
woke me up
and came up to me and licked me and and
uh i was like oh is this a toilet so i
took him to the toilet and he did a big
boy [ __ ] in the garden and he had a pee
and i was like yes i'm gonna [ __ ]
sleep he's done his debt he's done his
[ __ ]
and then
three hours later john's going rahul
rahul
the dog [ __ ] everywhere
all right but and then left and i was
like
how did this [ __ ] happen he did a
massive [ __ ] [ __ ] two hours so i was
i was so upset dogs don't they don't
follow any logic and
you've all met all of the foster dogs
and the poop saga between the three of
them
athena's still the worst
athena just like a mcflurry machine yeah
so athena was the second foster dog
oh dude worse less solid
she was the second foster and for her it
was a short-term one they were like hey
we have this dog who just needs a break
for a week she's like she's fine she's
cool she just needs like
a vacation for a week because she's
really um they call it high arousal
around other dogs so she just yeah they
do that they knew they knew she just
realized a lot of kids could empathize
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
but they were she was a short term when
they were like she just needs a break
because she doesn't sleep in the shelter
because she barks all the time because
she's hyped about other dogs so just
take her for a week and so i did and her
they were like nothing wrong with her
she's great and she's a really sweet dog
really friendly like very easy in terms
of like leaving her alone in the house
she just like
i put a sheet on the couch and she slept
on it it was great
but her [ __ ]
was so
liquidy
that ah you couldn't pick them up you
can't yeah it's just so guys sometimes
guys come on i had to wait a day
before going back to knowing where it
was just to harden for it so it would be
harder so i could pick it up
the problem with athena because i i i
met athena so bad i think you ordered
everyone
yeah she was really sweet she was really
sweet extremely sweet i i walked her a
few times because i had trouble walking
again yeah she's so aggressive and
overstimulated the wrong word she's not
aggressive just hyped
was it hyped it felt like she's not
aggressive
but she would pull like if she saw a cat
or a skunk or a dog
the the ferocity like how strong she'd
become
it was intense and like
it was you know
so i i i would i would
yeah she was a bit too strong for for
alana it's kind of intimidating even i i
struggled
um and if you're walking on a gradient
you're [ __ ] because that dog's just
gonna [ __ ] you're gonna end up like
skiing down a
[ __ ] road
or a hill that's actually pretty sick
yeah but because of because because
i felt like all right well i'll try and
like hold her back because it you know
it's neighborhood you're going to see
tons of dogs and stuff anyway um it
meant that i had to also deal with some
of that
mcflurry [ __ ] and one of them
she dropped one over the course of that
time that was
mcflurry so it was creamy
and it wasn't completely flat i do okay
okay i just yeah wait listen it wasn't
it wasn't you guys are new dog owners
and you have to understand no one wants
to hear about the dogs
the other day i was sitting there
playing elder ring rojo comes in from
outside speaks he monologues for four
minutes straight
about the dog's [ __ ] and i'm just it was
a good one i'm not even responding and
then
he goes
what am i doing what am i doing
okay first not new dog owners i've had
dogs my whole life second it's because
when they're fosters you have to
actually report on the consistency of
their shits
yeah well i guess we're not a humane
society
comedy podcast we are not above talking
about how gross dog shits are all right
i'm just saying
i think two dog [ __ ] stories yeah enough
that's fair enough so anyway you know
like how hogan does chocolate hogan does
if you leave it out yeah and it just
completely melts that's usually what
athena would drop so it's just this
chocolate puddle
and it's just a [ __ ] lap it would
just hit it and you'd be like oh but
anyway the one that she did drop which
was the best wheat i could have hoped
for or the best i saw was mcflurry-esque
so it still had a shaped solid ish to it
anyway i went to pick it up got it all
over my [ __ ] hands and it was the
beginning of the walk
and i didn't have there's no [ __ ]
it's not a park or anything it's just a
residential area so i'm like i've got
diarrhea on my hands i've tried to bag
it because she did it in someone's house
if it was a [ __ ] str i might leave it
and come back to it when it's hardened
she didn't have a house i had to the
water bottle just pour water on it i had
no water bottle and because she i i felt
like it was like weird social thing so
i'm i'm new to dogs well that was the
moral of my story rahul is that
dog shit's not a big deal
like a dog's
you you get a new dog that's gonna [ __ ]
in your house inevitably it happens
they don't know any different yeah no i
i get it i just mentioned a thing
whenever i go to a friend's house is i
just make sure to [ __ ] on their rug at
least once
just so that they know that i feel
comfortable
yeah
it well no i get it i just it was just
more that once i got moosie athena [ __ ]
all over my hands i spent the rest of
the walk because it had only just
started
holding my hand out like this
with dog
still waiting to pull going
for about 20 minutes
i feel like i've kind of stealed
from like animal poop just because cat
[ __ ] is so foul
i can handle anything at this point yeah
one time i sat down in human feces on a
park bench in san francisco
yep i sat on it
yeah oh yep oh sure you did
how to get inside your pants
they're really thin
jeans new texture um i had to go back to
the office i took my pants off and i
locked the door like to the bathroom so
that nobody else could enter while i was
in there um like with i held it with
like a broom or some [ __ ] and washed my
pants and they walked back i did and
then walked back out with wet pants jeez
what the [ __ ] am i gonna do so like the
only choice was to make it look like you
pissed yourself which is way better at
yourself
sat in someone else's [ __ ] it is a fun
game to play in san francisco is it
human feces or dog pieces you you just
remi i haven't thought about this in
years
it's not feces because i don't think
i've had a feces story but i remember
standing at a nightclub that we had just
got into in central london as i was like
22 or something all dressed up to the
nines
um friday night and as i got in what
does that look like in london
what's that what's dressing up to the
nines like could we take john and jacob
out and you could dress them as though
they were going to a club it's 21 year
olds
it's just well i mean things have
changed are just
a lot of the bouncers in london are very
uh they're [ __ ] i think is the word um
and
some like they're always looking for
they're looking for a reason to tell you
you can't come in whereas i don't feel
that that's been my experience in los
angeles or canada uh sorry vancouver but
in uh in london it's it's it's real
scope you up and down check your outfit
out now mate no trainers no sneakers uh
those are doc martens nah shoes only
i've been turned away because my shirt
they were like collars mate you need
collars on your shirt it's just they're
always going for a [ __ ] excuse so if
you really want to maximize your chance
all of you should as you've seen in the
in-betweeners episode
and always there is always one bell end
in your group that risks it and you're
like
and and it's you it's it's your boys so
like you can't even wear jordans
[ __ ] no really
like sneakers or whatever like
they can they they they can be
fashionable and it can make your outfit
look amazing but i understand it does
raise a bar so what happened ends up
happening is everyone goes in like smart
casual
um to maximize so it does elevate
that to a certain degree but so anyway
dressed up to the nines got all the way
to central london queued for [ __ ]
ages made it past the bouncers which is
like some dungeons and dragons boss
before you get in and then you finally
get in all right cool have a drink i'm
gonna go for a [ __ ] go outside go to the
smoking area start
and then a dude walked past me and went
and vomited down my legs
it was a drive-by vomit
did he run away he just carried him
walking because he was drunk so you
weren't allowed in
no i was in the smoking area but i
didn't want to stay i stunk of someone
else's vomit it was on my shoes and on
the thing i was like night's over barely
got started
um not feces obviously but yeah it just
reminded me about that oh my god yeah
that's gross
my color is really weird oh there we go
yeah sorry
yeah i agree
um you can't say that all right
i feel like maybe i told you guys about
when i threw up in berkeley
we were
we were driving home from a party a
house party i had i was still learning
my limits mm-hmm
and so we were driving down and it's
this long
windy street up in the berkeley hills
and so we're going back and forth
oh god and we get to the bottom and
there's this bar with like a bunch of
people outside it
and i roll the window down and i go hey
and everyone looks over and like
and then we just sped off did you do
that on purpose
yeah once i rolled the window down very
good and i saw all the people i was like
might as well that's really funny you
knew you were it was about to happen
yeah [ __ ] you just wanted to make a
statement out of it one night me and the
mandem
it was bo aaron and mo
um
we went to uh kingston oceana and um
bow uh australia yeah oceana um we um
beau was our designated driver he
doesn't drink so he drove us in his new
audi a3 that he he had just got um
and oh we get it you've got friends
who've got audis do ya
yeah is that a rich boy yeah that is i
don't have a friend who wants a [ __ ]
age i mean he's a working-class kid
i mean he bought that working in an
office so i don't know but anyway
um he drove us all the way because we
live a bit far out and i memo and aaron
got
[ __ ] wasted
and he had to get us all back into his
car and i remember little moe was
sitting up front next to bo and me and
aaron were in the back seat and mo was
doing this
uh in his seat and then i'd see him go
no
right and you're like oh [ __ ] and bo
starts going bruv if you [ __ ] bruv
bruv and and and
moe
like does the biggest like gob not puke
gob like collected gob like to try and
stay away from the vomit and went
and it the window was shut
and it just [ __ ] hit the vessel
and slid down the door it was like half
gob half puke
originally i questioned why women don't
listen to this podcast
well i just remember why is idiots and
abroad my least
least female engaged uh content
i i just remember everyone screaming in
the car just oh
and both swearing like
man them swearing talk you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] your brother
oh yeah yeah that's not great disgusting
they have an uber charge for a few
vomited cars right like yeah they charge
you
i mean i respect that because that's
gotta suck like the fact that they're
your own cars and you're letting them
out to drunk people people must see some
[ __ ] in it probably a lot of drunk
people i threw up on my 27th at
mcdonald's drive-through while ordering
i wasn't driving i was in the passenger
seat and it was i knew i was in trouble
it was my 27th birthday and i was
already in a really bad place like i had
was on i was on one rahul completely 110
mental
uh on my 27th and the amount of times i
had to be dragged away from some
[ __ ] i got myself into by the time
we got to the mcdonald's drive-thru
everyone started ordering and it was
like um can i get uh ten nuggets two
cheeseburgers what do you want you and
the food and the order even though i was
hungry was bringing on the
stop talking about food
and it was and i ended up like what and
then they were like what do you want
wrong i was like i'll get a large big
mac open the door
all down the [ __ ] drive shut the door
big mac mill cheeseburger and 10 nuggets
that's good it's just an interruption
that's just an introduction straight
back to it and then
i went
home to eat
and i went to the bathroom
and i needed to [ __ ] so i was [ __ ]
quick quick diarrhoea right
i was like oh and then i realized i
needed to throw up
so i like hit the flush turn around
i remember [ __ ] put my head in the
toilet and then i remember the toilet
seat fell down pick it back up and i
start puking
then i needed to [ __ ] again so i sat
back on and then i was sitting on the
toilet and i was wet in my face and i
was like what the [ __ ] is splashback
so touch my face
and my hands covered in blood
oh no oh and i came out of the toilet
uh so the downstairs toilet had a wooden
toilet seat and it was loose and my dad
needed to fix it and while i was puking
it had fallen down cracked me on the
edge of the nose i was so drunk i didn't
feel anything put it back up and sat
there and when i came out everyone
started screaming because they were like
he went to the toilet and then comes out
and just looked like i've been
yeah and then when it finally cleaned up
i just had this giant cut just across
the hinge oh no
good times
a lot of fluids man
there's that time you like the barf
between the legs while you're [ __ ]
situation you're getting [ __ ]
you're puking on your dick yeah as alana
always thinks will happen yeah i reckon
there's a lot of men out there who've
vomited on their own dicks all right i
want you to try to vomit through your
pants i want somebody to do the stats or
through your legs i don't think anyone
had i feel like it doesn't happen
because when you throw up you're already
leaning over yeah yeah but you're not
always chugging again i think i may have
said this on this podcast of why i think
it happens is
blaine did this
interview series for rooster teeth which
i think they only did once because it
like was maybe unethical where you would
ask yourself interview questions
get drunk and then answer your own
interview questions so you were
interviewing your drunk self why was it
unethical
oh because they were forcing people to
get like [ __ ] up hammered at work oh
which is like
like the fully funny stream like yeah
just like
anything wrong with that
and i mean blaine was so drunk that like
he um missed a flight to uh come see me
in san francisco for my birthday the
next day
so at least rooster teeth comped that
but i do have it on good authority that
blaine did leave you a present in san
francisco on a bench
[Laughter]
there's video and this is what sparked
it in my brain there's video footage of
him
sitting while he's supposed to be like
the drunk version of himself answering
questions and he just goes
and it's just all over he doesn't move
he's just sitting and it's just like i
saw that john sort of did that with the
vomit when we were doing games done slow
with the devil's toe
that was a snap that that one felt like
you just went more no that i did that on
purpose
it smells so bad
for comedy now that i think about it
like when i ate that spicy chip i think
it was that exact same kind of thing
where it just your body rejected it yeah
and it just jumped back out
i uh everyone is super distracted on
this podcast today we have gundams heat
stroke and a dog i'm done i finished i
don't know
that's sick a bunch of the bungalow boys
went to john holland's birthday party
and uh
i
i don't know what happened we were
drinking i was drinking too much and
then we played beer pong with
like stout or like like an ipa or
something
um what are you supposed to play bipong
with it's not very australian is there a
light beer okay just any like [ __ ] beer
okay
um
because then you can play it all night
and you don't even get drunk and you can
let a dirty ping pong land in it yeah
yeah i know what time we're driving home
yeah omar's driving matt peek's in the
passenger seat dan's in the back beside
me
i'm i'm looking out the front going
all right i can make it home i just
gotta stare forward like this i can make
it home i can make it home just like
this
and then i hear the window crack
and i look over and dan is
trying to get his head out the window
and i was like no dan don't do it and he
started throwing up and then immediately
i was like no
and so i roll down the window stick my
head out my new glasses because i just
got in a prescription gotten glasses i
had them for like two months
flew off my face oh also that's [ __ ]
expensive i know we spoke about glasses
last time this cost me so much
oh yeah i was going to order multiple
pairs to have like different styles i'm
like [ __ ] i can't afford more than one
pair of [ __ ] glasses check out me
our sponsors if they want to
one of my cousins went to like the fair
or something and won a balloon or some
[ __ ] and i just which was little tied
into her glasses
when they're going home some [ __ ] on the
freeway open the window
and the [ __ ] balloon
shot off with the glasses her
prescription had just floated away
that's
somewhere in france a blind little boy
it just landed
wow there's this i've forgotten about
these all these repressed memories are
coming back you guys keep triggering
these please so john i think you
remember you telling me this before a
long time ago so you and dan were
blasting out both sides of the car both
sides
were just like oh god so they stopped at
a gas station got us waters
and both of us are just going i'm sorry
yeah oh sorry but that made you so but
you would have been fired do you think
you'd have been fine if dan hadn't
appeared i was going to throw up but i
think i could have made it home that's
what happened to me in japan i think i
like told half the story but um james or
japan japan itself cole galleon
uh bunch of us went out
one of my japanese friends ken
took us on this ridiculous tour and got
us very drunk and i think i told the
story already about how i like almost
didn't get my visa and couldn't get on
the plane and it was a disaster
cole vomited in the taxi on the way back
to our airbnb and i surely would have
vomited but i think i could have held it
and then when i got in the airbnb i
realized there was vomit on my dress and
i was like who vomited on me
and blaine and miles were like you did
honey oh that was yours and i was like
no it was just coal
gold did this to me
you watch someone else do it and you go
oh [ __ ] there i go that was like um
we were at that um
winter thing for uh for rooster teeth
and we went to get pizza
at uh what was the pizza place called i
don't know home slice home slice that's
right that's right
like i was really drunk because it was
after like a holiday party thing
and i was just sitting there and the
pizza hadn't come yet and i was like i'm
just having a good time
oh i'll be right back so i just like
walked to the bathroom and just
it's one of my favorite jacob stories
because you like briskly walked off
you're like i'll be right back and then
you were gone for 15 minutes or
something maybe 20. and then you came
back and we're completely fine again
ready for pizza yeah i [ __ ] love that
pizza it's good [ __ ] i just had to make
some room yep
i hate vomiting i hate it so much
i think we spoke about it but you'll be
good sometimes you get to take care of
me
uh my birthday when i was dressed as
zombies yeah the star wars birthday that
was you vomited on your shoes
on my jedi boots
you were like basically outside
christmas cool costume too you're like
i'm sorry
it was very dramatic he was so drunk
i know he started he lost his phone in
an uber and i started a fight with
anthony carboni though it was a chaotic
night yeah that was a lot of chaos that
night the milk yeah good times you know
that's where i got those great pictures
me guys laughing at my ass crack when i
thought that we were friends yeah you
thought they would be in buds we were
just laughing at your ass crack ben 24
hot like they were laughing at you i
lost my jedi robe there that place took
a lot i found a video
like i didn't even remember happening of
me just as a jedi
with a group of people outside trying to
ollie on a skateboard
yeah that was around the time that you
were just spoiled
yeah
um speaking of which i we were going to
try and figure it out but my schedule's
invest right now so it wouldn't have
worked
if i reckon for
12 episodes we do it live
in la
as we did the live episode but it'll
actually be our 12th episode rather than
a one-off and um
i'm to see if we can do it at scum
ability
because they have a podcast set up so
we'll see if we can get a little live
audience and do episode 12 live which
would be
july
i think
math
that'd be
i would like to ask viewers
how do you feel about live sound
well that um generally is terrible right
but that
the whole of fat man beyond
mark bernardin and kevin smith's podcast
is always recorded there
oh really and it sounds good
jacob
don't worry about it when did he get so
[ __ ]
and raul your chat thing i'm doing
display couch so it just like popped up
oh
it said
[ __ ] flaps please
got it i think i pulled something that's
what happens when you
show the man of your [ __ ] flaps it's
hard it's hot out here sorry to
interrupt about scummability that sounds
awesome i thought it would be sick and
yeah they do a really good job that
sounds amazing this is my first time
hearing it and i approve
all right
um
you are my permission hey thanks john
that means a lot
we have some questions from people on
patreon that i thought what
questions
questions
questions that need answering i love
this question sam said how difficult is
it to schedule time with rahul uh now
that he's a big shot hollywood man
rahul's the most tough one to schedule
for sure yeah
yeah yeah i'm so busy
actually
sometimes yeah sometimes a big spurts he
didn't say his agent too
we
[Music]
this is such a low minimum
it doesn't require any prep at all yeah
we
zoom for a couple of hours we do is tell
each other to shut up in advance and be
like save it yeah
yeah
it's uh and i i really enjoy it because
it's just a nice
i don't know like yeah it's a travel pog
whatever the [ __ ] whatever god we say it
is but really it's just a really nice
zoom call yeah
that i enjoy um
yeah it's brilliant yeah it's it's super
easy and we usually do it on the
weekends right i feel like we always
record on a weekend we've done a few oh
my god
what what
i'm not in missouri anymore
yeah dude that at all i was talking
about it last episode no but i was gonna
say john you haven't said on this
episode why you're in l.a
oh
right i'm back at funhouse there you go
what you're employed again
and now jacob's gonna quit you're of
adventuring is over yeah how do you feel
john like it it it took more of a toll
on you than i think you expected
traveling a lot of small like stability
look at him he's in a he's in a a vest
sunburn
sweaty
it looks like he just got back from his
travel side
never again is it easy to tell myself
that but then i do is it egotistical
that the only two uh pieces of art that
i hung in that rooms are things that i
painted
oh did you is that narcissistic nah okay
we display jacob displays gundams he
built that's true that's true yeah i've
got miniatures and gundams as well
though all those tasteful nudes that
yeah you hang behind you all the time
that's a good point let me take it but i
need to tell you guys about the road
trip i took with my dad yeah let's do it
it was fun
not much happened
okay well
so my dad
uh
hold on your dad was very sweet i met
him he's a nice man
the only one who's whose dad i haven't
met is jacob jacob can i meet your dad
absolutely cool you could be scott let's
make it happen my father is 67 years old
he drove out from san diego to missouri
in his van by himself and then we loaded
his van and the car
and
i
i i am a sickly boy who stays inside all
the time he carried way more boxes down
the
third from the third floor that's a very
supportive dad behavior i mean the last
episode you were packing right
yeah
so you made it oh yeah my dad was there
yeah he looked like a
home alone
joey pesci's beanie yeah that's great no
i met him he was really nice your dad's
really sweet
yeah sweet man he's a cool guy very
deadly
um but so on the trip the only real
things that happened was the second day
rocky mountains
hey
don't you threaten me
uh we went over the rocky mountains and
it was like 20 degrees and snowing
and uh my dad was like freaking out i
was i was fine
i mean did you take pictures because
that shit's beautiful
i did that was why i almost got in an
accident because i was
it was all windy
um
but also my dad goes to bed at like 9 00
p.m
so by the time i got here my sleep
schedule uh
like i got here and then i had to see i
laid down at like eight
i got very upset with rahul for this he
does this cough thing that is like that
that clip of that guy drinking the water
who then coughs rahul coughs like this
[Laughter]
like a joke without a hot dog yeah like
you know that video clip of the guy who
drinks from the water bottle and and
then he like spills on himself and goes
no i think
man
oh yeah when you arrived i had to
so your dad was asleep and i had to
record a podcast and i think it might
have been
like a one that was not appropriate and
i was so conscious of the fact that your
dad was sleeping and never very close to
me and i was 20 feet away yeah
i was like nice christian man and i
don't think i think i was trying to be
conscious of it but i don't feel like it
was very appropriate it's fine my
parents stopped watching the podcast
because they got to the episode where i
was talking about hooking up with a
prostitute
they got pretty thought through all
things considered yeah yeah that's good
progress my cousin listens to this show
i don't know if any of my other family
members do but i also feel like i don't
you know my stories are really boring in
comparison yeah
[ __ ]
my brother my mom
and the boys i think listen
tori our building manager at fun house
he listens really
that that bring warms my heart because
he loves tech9 who's awesome yeah tech9
is awesome my uh co-star who i adore uh
his name's sorry oh
you've seen it probably seen a clip um
saurian listens apparently to idiots so
when i try and tell him stuff he's like
i was like oh yeah i was just backing it
he's like yeah i know i heard it on the
podcast
[Laughter]
yeah repeated podcast content it's also
like when you get to ten episodes or
something and we keep doing two hours we
repeat we're repeating stories
but the people know i don't know how
they [ __ ] remember and i don't
oh i wanted to i wanted to bring
something up real short yes go ahead
remember scissor paper stone
yes
yes um i wanted to ask you lot
the game
that you
played as a kid where you knock on
someone's front door and run away what
do you call it
ding dong ditch ding dong dish
what
what
ours is called knock down ginger what
the [ __ ] what
why
what the [ __ ]
explain i explained this but anytime i
tell these things all the comments are
like nah he's wrong uh
firstly i believe your experience
believe women
thank you
um but everyone was like no we don't say
scissor paper stone we say rock paper
scissors i was like it's regional though
because i have australians to be like we
don't say a shoe and i'm like well maybe
two of you [ __ ] don't somewhere i
don't know a lot of australians do i
didn't say everyone
ultimately i think we can all agree that
we all hate you in the comments yes even
the ones that say nice things i hate you
i have so many alt accounts just so that
i can comment on alana's videos
so
i usually just keep but i reply to every
one of alana's videos and social media
with just you know what you're doing
[Laughter]
every single thing
i know even when she has even when she
has a sad video yeah even if she has a
sad video where she's like hey this is
happening in my life or i've got my okay
yeah you're doing it yeah
there's one yeah that's a whole [ __ ]
flap my god
oh this is a lot of leg
i can't i can't do it because my
poncho's too big okay
oh
wait what are you are you wearing pants
on under the poncho
how can i find out only one way to find
out
i can show you the full puncture but so
are you gonna tell us why it's as told
by ginger or whatever yeah what the [ __ ]
is that
nice poncho bro that's sick yeah that's
[ __ ] that's sick lifts it up it's my
dick
[Music]
why is it moving like that
uh no i don't want to just go i'm going
to google it to make sure because other
brits are going to be like he's moving
ridiculous that is ridiculous that's
what how i read every comment
um knocked down ginger is that what he
said
ginger down ginger that's not ginger
okay
knock down ginger is a prank where kids
run up to someone's house ring the
doorbell and run away before being seen
that's what we call it knock why do you
call it that do you hear
a red-headed kid over beforehand this is
interesting because once here it says
knock on wikipedia it says knock knock
ginger and then the next one says knock
down ginger but yeah knock knock ginger
at least makes a little bit more sense
yeah no i thought that'd be like if you
beat up a redhead knock down ginger
either though
i think that you have to maybe in
england
you have to
knock over a redheaded kid before you do
it
which you probably have a few of based
on the proximity to ireland and scotland
oh but that sucks
they know they're getting knocked down
at some point what are you guys excited
you guys call in the uk the game where
whoever has the ball everyone tries to
get them
oh here it's a tara it i don't know what
people oh that was a racial slur
no
homophobic sir yeah oh no the only game
i know that involved like
beating people up uh was it's called um
well on the streets wait you said
whoever's got the ball everyone watch
out the boss someone gets the ball and
then everyone else has to tackle him man
our
our version of that
the version we played was called nutmeg
rush
and nutmeg rush was you'd all be on the
playing field or in wherever you were
with the football
and if you got nutmegged
which is when someone puts the ball
through your legs
you get beaten up by everyone who's
there whether it's 20 people
why would anyone want to play that it's
[ __ ] hell we used to play it all the
time it's dope like yeah you literally
then people are like especially if
you're you don't want to get a beat in
and someone's forcing the [ __ ] ball
through your legs and you're like trying
to shut them and they're like kicking it
through but yeah if you get nutmeg
uh you get jumped but you also like a
lot of a lot of the games we played
always resulted in
it's called a rushing i guess like
so it was your birthday you get rushed
um the ball goes through your legs get
rushed
um your mom died get rushed does that
mean you get beat up or what yeah rushed
is like a uh that's the word we would
use i mean i'm old now but um
when you were getting rushed it was when
you were getting beaten up by multiple
people yeah all right we all got rushed
different kind of childhood games which
is also very much at all i traded
pokemon
yeah
like red rover and stuff where it's just
two lines of children running at each
other and then one at a time will sprint
full speed at the other ones because all
the arms are locked together what you
just try to break through them you
didn't play slaps you didn't play or
slap like knuckles like
no we didn't beat each other knuckles
yeah it was always unofficial just like
people like oh who would you knuckles
right now
so in high school we did slap fighting
where all the theater kids parked their
cars
in a circle with the headlights on and
then everyone was shirtless and they
were all sweaty and like rubbing each
other are you serious
and you had to
you locked hands like this and then it
was slapping back and forth that sounds
sick
yeah it was cool
why did it feel dramatic my favorite was
always stuck in the mud which was like
stuck in the mud yeah yeah yeah i loved
it i loved that i was a big fan of stuck
in the mud yeah someone has to go
through your legs in it yeah it's just
stuck yeah yeah to free you out i really
enjoyed it the co-op of it uh one of my
favorite things to contrast like your
commentary about british school games is
everybody getting rushed there's a thing
that i keep noticing recently is the
amount of british names that just add 10
suffixes so like the british locations
are just like
woodland hill
shireford and they just keep adding
shire fords
and there's 10 of them why woodland
hills would be fine why has it got to be
chyafid lanestone 10. just so many of
them i don't understand why it's
necessary
you should um if you think that's bad
look at uh welsh
stuff like welsh names and welsh words
one of my favorite accents in the world
oh yeah i love it i wrote it and read
letters but um that was bad it's not
we had uh the uk ign team really got
away with [ __ ] that the us didn't so the
uk boys were allowed to swear shout out
to daniel cropper i only
yeah he's great group is awesome they're
all great um even the i think croup is
one of the ones who left but uh gav is
um welsh
doesn't sound yeah he didn't sound uh
from the uk gav
it's true they now do uh rkg they were
prepared to try which was like a popular
um dark souls series that ign had and
they were allowed to swear and there's
this one wolfenstein preview video that
gav did the
uh vo for that is this welsh accent
going mario and goomba
like the amount of times that i listen
to that mario and goomba sherlock and
moriarty
is there anyone is there anyone on ign
who was scouse
no never any scousers
um
yeah i think scouse scouts people from
liverpool it's nice
again fable uh the lost chapters one of
my favorite games ever made has scouse
accents in it so does um we always this
always comes up when we talk about
scouse accents pierce uh kuno from pino
kuno kini from uh disgusting
wait rahul you you found out something
amazing recently about liverpool they
have a big fan
[Laughter]
this morning oh
yeah i was tagged in a picture
this has set us back
yes
uh best fans in the world
liverpool we call ourselves
um
jacob what are you doing unironically we
call ourselves the best fans in the
world and then this morning i saw this
which is uh
it's a jake paul in a liverpool gear i
said this to you
when i saw this i don't i'm not in the
interest of gatekeeping football like
obviously anytime i talk about football
i'm gate kept and i'm not interested in
doing that to anybody else
but the way he phrased the tweet is
what's the tweet because i just have the
pictures
really [ __ ] strange hold on can you
show the picture again
jake paul
was he doing this
good question uh he
do yeah yeah he's flexible so his shirt
has m salah on it big fan big fan of
masala
um it the the tweet is shout outs to
masala at masala liverpool rivalry today
but my apologies to everton the blues
are getting spanked by the reds
it's
just the most generic tweet that you
could write
it's just strange it's just an odd um
tweet and and then he also tweeted
divock origi afterwards which i agree i
do agree
i regret the things i've said in the
past about divock i've been a little
hard on him you're also hard on mo
yeah yeah i think sometimes you should
pass but yeah but you're also on the
train of
nah he's leaving he's [ __ ] i'll tell
you something i've spoken to you about
boys
to you about sorry
you
like
you're
you
because like became a fan of liverpool
when when mo was there right
i mean yeah my family i have liverpool
fans in my channel yeah yeah yeah you
have your connection in terms of you
watching dedicated enough
you watched everything actually watching
and stuff and then
go ahead jacob go ahead is masala the
one with like the giant crevice in his
abs yeah i knew he's got your hair
you're on board yep oh cool it does kind
of come down with that yeah but but and
your abs your your love affair for mo
salah
is
like
what i had
for
fernando torres and louis suarez and the
heartbreak of when they're like peace uh
it's [ __ ] awful and i love mud again
and it's it's almost like i'm like
distancing myself and i do love him yeah
and i'd be devastated if he left yeah
because if he does go this summer pierce
i you're the pain in your chest that
you're gonna feel and then when it's
then when it's the louis diaz or the
next person that we treat like mo salah
like we treat with louis suarez and
torres i think you're gonna pull back
too and be like well you know they might
be gone it was just that there were so
many rumors that just like every two
months um jake paul also has a tweet
again i'm not in the business of trying
to gatekeep football
it says
liverpool controlling this entire game
great win man united ain't man united
without ronaldo
but they have been for a while mate yeah
he doesn't know what he's talking about
but then united never been united on
saturday man united haven't been united
since sir alex so the replies thing
it's totally wrong
so the replies think that he's trying to
get football i'm glad you got sunstroke
while he's not boxing
i just want to say i'm glad you got
sunstroke no don't say that
he could die all right have i ever told
you about in melbourne in australia in
summer it gets real hot and it it's like
40 i don't know oh really it gets hot in
summer 40 what
40 such a small number what do you guys
call the the sun in australia the sun's
always a
is uh
the sun is
she gonna end the call oh
oh thank god
did she stop video [ __ ] you guys um so
no there are heat waves you son of a
[ __ ] you sack of [ __ ] i hope you feel
bad you piece of [ __ ] say it alone i say
what i just said tell him you're glad he
got a heat stroke
i don't know i would say that um it gets
to like 110 120 and all the old people
just died
just
just get too hot and they just [ __ ]
give up they die in drugs
in melbourne wait then why do all why
why does everyone retire in [ __ ]
nevada
that's a great question
so all of our old people in the uk they
die the winter because they can't afford
the [ __ ] heating bills and they they
freeze
yeah maybe uh in melbourne
i'm i'm going to be honest with you have
i been have i been tame on this podcast
you as the audience and everyone can get
used to it i ain't saying nothing
anymore
i need i need everybody to know that i
did not love what raffle said i laughed
at john's fake law
yeah john laughed at the elderly in the
uk
oh [ __ ] i'm sorry about that's sad i
thought
aren't you like more socialist though
who are you asking the uk
i lost a friend over a podcast comment
not on this podcast and ever since then
i don't want to say nothing no more
about nothing
how do you feel about don't be a [ __ ]
no i am a [ __ ] um
i'm trying to find a way to find
something that pisses you off
you are like i'm afraid it's delicate
i'm saying mum's
um
can you give us a breakdown of
daisy ridley and like how compelling her
performances were um particularly in the
last film
in
skywalker i forgot the name of the movie
yeah
death on the nile all i know is
all i know is that
when you see pictures from celebration
and you see like have you seen like
young girls cosplaying as ray like how
important that character is and that
visibility that's my [ __ ] answer just
gave me my own [ __ ] rebuttal right
back to me i think no matter what the
issues are with the script writing on
that level and
whether she was op or whether disney's
new movies they break some of the uh
whatever it means it's all it all means
nothing
when
it means nothing like the most important
thing is when you see a young girl
dressed as ray
going to school that's what that's what
star wars is about yeah that's all that
matters so
i'm a big fan of daisy ridley and um
yeah she actually seems really cool yeah
she does she seems like she seems like
she'd actually be pretty sick yeah
moving garbage i told you i'm not doing
this no more you might as well represent
it's really good you're gonna have to
replace some beef curtains
sorry
not damn you're talking [ __ ] alana knows
i i i mean i'm being vulnerable i like
genuinely upset got guys yeah yeah i
know it's right really upset me then i'm
like
and it wasn't even my fault really but
um yeah so i'm like ass not worth this
no more so
no more spicy takes huh
i need a spicy take from you right now
to know
that you are still my friend rahul oh
and not a robot a shell of a man that's
great
you all you've witnessed of me is now i
don't make spicy jokes and i clean up
dog poo and i don't say that dog out of
my sight i've changed you've been
domesticated you make tea
and crumpets okay it still takes him
half an hour and you can't happen quick
it's i was joking it's one of my
favorites is you'll ask for tea and then
he'll be like yeah yeah and then he
boils it four times it's worth
everything i'm just forgetting to do it
shout out to my mom who will feel heard
right now because that's one of her
biggest complaints about me is the
kettle being boiled forward yeah but
then my kettle has a hold button yeah so
you're kind of pretty sick i'm sure it
holds but but it looks like it will
never spill because it's got this stout
like spout sorry that's super accurate
and whatever get it out i feel like i
pour it all over yeah you just gotta not
tip it yeah it's because it's too full
so when you tip you tip it too far and
it pours out the top
shout out to phil tippet happens to me
every time
um one of my favorite things i just
can't learn rahul boiling the kettle
four times is that if you get up to make
the tea he gets offended he's like nah
i'm doing it
i would never i wait every time
yeah i respect that that's i've been
making strat down i've been making john
t
yeah yeah that's actually although you
want to make sure you mention tea and i
thought that i was going to get it and
then you came and sat down with the cup
john dry
yesterday i did i did i broke all
etiquette uh he did leave you with dog
[ __ ]
well he was awesome yeah you [ __ ]
left me i'm not i'm cool i'm zen i don't
care whatever you should do it's my dog
like it was my response
yes exactly good
poop on the bed or something
what a wild thing to do
have you seen the pictures of
that are taking a split second between
her
not hearing that and then
johnny depp being like she [ __ ] the bed
and playing around the dog
it's like she's like
has this like condescending look and
then it's her just
like why not what an insane thing to do
oh my god it wasn't on purpose what a
couple what a couple but it well
actually maybe it was i assumed it was
yeah i don't know i assumed that it was
so well behaved trying to think about
well you had a lot of opinions about it
uh before we started the podcast sorry
no trust
trying to summon spice out of you i'm
trying to think of other things that
trigger raffle other than star wars
big gray beard pointy eye
seen him in three well
you have some of the worst fashion i've
ever seen
yeah your shoes your sweats you sound
like my sister
that's my my nadia was on my case
no i i genuinely got a call from my
sister and she's like
you know
look at your colleagues and code look at
the effort they make look at all the
wonderful clothes they wear and stuff
like they present themselves and you
[ __ ] walk around in [ __ ] sweats
and a liverpool shirt
[Laughter]
you're
it does it's great i just got suggested
the underwear so now i can be complete
oh my gosh they sell that unless you've
got one to show us i don't want to put
you on the spot that's uncomfortable but
if you
wait i'm not wearing them shut the [ __ ]
up and show your [ __ ] jacob no jacob
i'm wearing the shirt right now but not
the underwear you're not wearing the
underwear not well
isn't your rule supposed to be that as
long as you're wearing one piece of
destiny clothing at all times you're all
right yeah then you're fine the ren fair
like st patrick's day with the ren fair
i wasn't wearing i was wearing
only destiny socks
wow i didn't i didn't realize yeah it's
stealthy
but i met my quota do you have we need
to get your destiny condoms
i mean yeah i got them i got them oh
surely i don't use them
nice
uh safe sex everyone yeah shout out yeah
practice
but ooh baby what about the time that we
watched um the bunny ranch show finally
and it's just got actual [ __ ] in it
and i was like you have to close
alone
your blinds were broken because of the
dog yeah
so there's no way to shut them
and well john's john's like oh i've got
the cat house dvd and we're sitting
there what were we eating we had some
food we had dinner
it was like chipotle or something yeah
we was eating chipotle burrito bowls
while they look at it like
with their legs behind her someone eaten
us
also like there was a dildo on a drill
yeah
and it's not like alana's got like a
small tv
she's got like this giant [ __ ] 85
oled
with the hue lights so which anyone who
walks by it's just going hey check this
the [ __ ] thing out and it's just like
someone drilling a dildo into a
it was a live porn you're gonna get
another uh
another email
yeah my memory about that show was all
of the stuff in between well they
probably do the porn stuff to get you in
on the first episode oh yeah i'm pretty
sure uh as a young whippersnapper i
masturbated to cat house
really
was did it
well sky or cable whatever
wow it's so raunchy
yeah it was but i think it might have
been sensitive as well i think it might
have been cut down it wasn't they cut
the sex out
all of it but probably some bits because
we definitely saw buttholes right and we
saw some dick
yeah we did yeah a lot of boobs
yeah boobs yeah boobs all day long right
i feel like we saw some genres
there was a really gross episode you
showed us where the
one of the uh girls that work there
was
kind of treated really poorly by these
douchebags that's actually a really
interesting thing for them to include
though because usually they probably
would just disclude that but they showed
up being like yeah i work here but i'm
going to treat you with respect and
you're going to treat me like we have
boundaries it was like a really
interesting perspective to hear
especially considering how old that show
is
yeah but it ruins the wank and
i i
i'm trying to get through the whole
episode it's not funny it's not funny
don't laugh at that it's not come on
rauh why would you say that he didn't
make it very far look at him
whatever
um look at my arms
oh my god i haven't seen your eyes oh
that's why you asked for the aloe vera i
could give you um no no i found it i do
have like a whole bottle of it right
yeah yeah good [ __ ] oh my god sorry
about that bud you didn't think to wear
sunscreen how's jacob still look so
you know jacob wears sunscreen and he's
a little bit he also had one of those
bee suits
oh
the hot dog suit
do you guys know what omar's like when
he's drunk
yeah he's a good time omar's great i
feel like i've been drunk with omar yeah
it's fun yeah it's just delightful
so
more omaha but like yeah exactly
he's also i don't think he ever really
gets like smashed yeah omar thinks that
there's a small possibility that him and
anna diamos are related yeah really
they're from the same area yeah
same name i think i've heard this uh
from omar this this
can we all agree all four of us that
that is one beautiful
talented ridiculously oh yeah
yeah i haven't watched dark water yet
me and alana need to watch the [ __ ]
film that i've been asking us to watch
for the last
however many you guys have been too busy
watching gran torino
dude that's the best part of that movie
the movie ends
and the music's playing the credits
start to roll and you just hear so
it's clint
what is it is it really and it's clinton
and jaime
i looked it up and he has a bunch of
credits on film soundtracks yeah i think
he can sing but he's obviously at that
point like you know he's throwing all
those cigars
[ __ ] weird
uh yeah john john and i have been
correcting thinking that you guys
watched that over like two nights
yeah
we're watching her
for a few dollars more over two weeks
john
i'm not the person who fell asleep 10
minutes into our viewing
of what and then going how far did we
get of what
a few dollars more dude you know why i'd
also watched it the week before i'm only
re-watching it so i could sit with you
just so you can appreciate it okay well
for all you listening i said i was just
i was going to watch them and they're
all who was like oh but we need to watch
them together
i was like oh okay yeah because i told
you i've lost i lost a friend and i'm
trying to make new friends and trying to
do nice things and be forward thinking
because i'm sad so i was like i'd like
to watch those movies with you it's
instead of just [ __ ] mocking me but
that's all right
i really don't like your energy right
now can i just say hey can i just say
just firstly hey can i just can you plug
the podcast you're doing rahul i don't
know can i i think it'll be yeah i've
done it yet
by the time this airs you will no maybe
not
what a date i think it's fine i don't
think he cares yeah come on
podcast do it yeah you won't have done
oh my god stevie weeby i'm doing the
stevie
stevie show oh cool
yeah hello uh fellow chomidy podcast um
you know all the comedians in the
podcasting space just we we just like we
have so many great friends
in the comedy podcast community um that
it's so cool to be able to collaborate
with them yeah we are
what people don't realize
um alana is very close to louis ck
oh
widely known
um
the two we've listed at joe rogan and
louis ck
apologies to stevie weeby who we
actually think is super cool
andrew santino
huge fan oh yeah
yeah i'm a pretty big fan
i have like a little bit of a crush on
him
knock down ginger don't make me knock
down knock down ginger
uh
we like um bobby lee bobby lee we love
bobby lee bobby yeah what
there's something about his honesty and
like that's what we were just
referencing for the for the record
listener at home was the i really don't
like your energy right now can i just
say something
every time he's
yeah i love the way he just was he would
be hey can i just can i just say
something right now every what you just
said i'm i'm really [ __ ] mad right
now i just want to kind of just say
like i'm going to walk out i love that
he does that it is good um
yeah yeah sorry i'm actually serious
about it
yeah
yeah
he uh uh john introduced delano annoyed
to
bobby lee and bad friends i don't
remember that doesn't didn't aaron as
well
and and my boy aaron yeah but it was
john and aaron tag teamed basically i it
was just that when i was in vancouver
shooting something
aaron was walking around with this
t-shirt on
and
seriously like i want to say like 10 to
15 people in vancouver stopped him over
his t-shirt oh wow and it was and i
didn't know who it was i was like what
the [ __ ] it it was tiger belly it was
a picture we got to get merch lads we
got to figure it out actually john while
you're in my domain i was going to talk
to you about that euphemism
[Laughter]
he's totally directed about me right now
yeah we need to figure out how much that
would be sick and i was going to be like
how does how did pizza [ __ ] work and
how how do i just got a pizza posse
chart didn't i john
yeah i gave it to you
and got dog [ __ ] on it that morning
oh my god i got dark [ __ ] on my mocks
yeah do we have this from john now i
have a bunch of jungles i don't have any
clothes it's on your ring camera alana
him stepping in
no it fully is it's on one of my
security cameras is
john walks out sees a skunk
steps and gets distracted looks down
like you could see the whole turn of
events it's very good that's great yeah
i would love a pet skunk they really
can't you can do it and and yeah you
should remove their you don't even have
to you don't even have to remove their
hands can't you replace it with like
febreze so they're like a glade
and it just smells like linen no you
don't have to because they'll only spray
if they're super threatened so if you
domesticate them they you don't have to
do this one
yeah
no but what it would do
no but if guests came around they would
always spray a nice spray of febreze
yeah because they'd immediately i don't
know who you are and then
i think this was how mobius was created
i was going to say we should ask the
scientists about this but i think this
is kind of the situation that led to
mobius that's my favorite
that's one of my favorite actors
right now
now you know what you look like lana
look you look like you're in the vr room
in the finale of izombie
yeah i loved that actually i gave the
dog the um 2k
camera
oh
little babe
oh he's twitching
oh he's dreaming doing some running
where are you going bud i'm chasing
rabbits
ask alice
i miss him oh jon's running down dog
i'll leave it there i'll leave it
you know people online say looks like me
he's hearing him
[Music]
you don't look like him that's racist
you should cancel all of them
lucky bear lucky little man
you got pat by a dude who's bright
[ __ ] red rubble you should shave your
butt and we'll compare
just shave that that hip see how it goes
it's so much cooler out there
it's pretty cool we've only got another
two hours john don't worry we look like
we're dressed for different climates
yeah
yeah that's right we technically are i
still i need to figure out how it works
but then i have to pay somebody to do it
guys can i just say something i
personally say something i'm not in
vancouver um
and it makes me so happy to look on zoom
and see this background as opposed to
that [ __ ] hotel that i've been in
since january
um yeah but you're going back right
yeah i'm not finished i'm not wrapped
i still owe
some scenes um and we have some reshoots
coming up so
uh i have to keep the hair long for now
i can't shave anything off give us
you're going to shave your head
no like you know when you when i usually
when i when i finish a character
you look very cute right now first thing
i do is i get a haircut i just like to
change my look from what i've had to
keep um
uh
so i yeah
something that would be shitty about
being an actor is that you have no
ownership over
how you look really um
people get to tell you
yeah a bit i mean again super privileged
problems uh
obviously well compensated for it so i
don't want to get on a soapbox about it
it's part of the job it's part of the
job but i just i just can't believe that
sometimes you don't get to choose your
own haircut
i just think that like that's yeah awful
but i also i could be so hard i could be
working why do they keep giving you such
like doofus looking haircuts
i play doofuses i i you know i i could
be you know working in a
factory or you know an officer it's
no
no they they still get to choose their
hairstyle you know
i can't
there are some like if you work for
amazon you can't you know you can go
through it you can't even go for pee
breaks i don't know why you guys are
making fun of the
people but we're not making fun of them
i'm making fun of people who think that
the haircut part is important how did
you miss the layers of the joke
amazon workers
i've lost i've lost my humor but now now
you have to explain everything we've got
a [ __ ] sjw on the podcast i know who
is this man
no princess well on the side of the
amazon workers unionized my friends i'm
so sorry to all of you that amazon tried
to stop from unionizing it's super
[ __ ] up i saw an amazon commercial
pro union
and they played them on twitter it was
during the soccer game this morning and
it was like
you should work at amazon because amazon
loves their employees and their
employees families and we don't need
unions
we will [ __ ] murder you if you even
think about it
you get a free water bottle to piss in
on every shift it's just possible so
much money
[Laughter]
well right back to poop
we thought we made it out brought us
right back in i know bears got it better
than those amazon workers he does
yeah but like rahul has to cut his hair
you know and i just
feel like we should talk about that okay
i have one more question from patreon oh
yes the questions
did that come up jacob did that come up
on the screen
also yeah john why doc moon derek oh
he's gonna oh he's gonna do it
dark me and derek's badass who's dogma
derek wait wait wait i don't know
jacob show foot do it jacob i'm waiting
for it we have to throw a bunch of coins
at him
it's it's happening just kick my desk
oh
that's what happens when you old man and
you trust your foot
um
alana didn't hear it because she had her
headphones in but when i went down to
pet
bear i went into a deep squat and i
accidentally farted
oh my
sorry
i thought it would pick up on the
microphone
it may have i have no idea um
okay question from patreon this one's
from portlink who's the worst person to
be around when they suddenly get drunk
which of us is the worst to be around
suddenly trump jacob just gets happy and
quiet jacob's great jacob's great or
loud i've been getting quite loud lately
oh jacob's in his obnoxious face well i
feel like late i've i've just had with
things going the way they do i've just
been drinking
at gatherings more often so it's just a
long period of time
getting out of there now that the things
are opening up a little bit more you
there's more of a pull to go socialize
and go bars and stuff oh yeah
everybody's like we need to spend
every minute together well there's been
more just like occasions that people
organize are you making fun of me john
how i've been with you
[Laughter]
sorry rahul um
nobody is uh
we understand your sensitivities we're
really sorry about
hiding your feelings and not taking your
feelings into consideration yeah but
also it might be sorry about that
[Laughter]
oh by the way it's not i actually don't
know i think all of you are good drunks
i was only going to say sometimes rahul
like
i've seen him try to start a fight
i didn't struggle at times
one time he put this woman in a headlock
yeah
decta actually no i did put someone in a
headlock i did put someone in the
headlock when i was out with bruce
yeah you did you did you did yes yeah i
know that can be a problem tried to
headbutt someone when i was out with the
lawn now it's a thing that i think that
people don't know about you rahul is
that you've been
doing it less but you talk [ __ ] online
and the thing is that most people who
talk [ __ ] on twitter would never do it
in real life you absolutely would the
[ __ ] that you talk on twitter you you
would do it in person and i think people
don't register that
within your country within
yeah but within reason like i'll stand
up
i'll stand up for myself i'm not a bully
like it's i'm reactive i don't just look
for someone like the guys
has come at the expense of people being
shitty to women actually
yeah well just you know whenever you get
heated
i feel a little blood rushed down in my
penis
why did you say penis sleep so john we
had a john and i
had a story and this proves that i don't
just like i'm i'm not a psychopath like
i just if my friends need me or if it's
gonna pop off i'm there like and if i
feel disrespected and someone said
something regardless of size or whatever
i'll i'll stand up penis no [ __ ] that
yeah what did you say
um yeah how big do you take
tiny
but that's not a problem by the way if
you have a small bit there's not a
problem particularly you know that
that's a real problematic you know
i want to stop doing the small dick
jokes to be honest i think
yeah we're all growers growers but uh
john john and i mean john and i had an
experience
that every [ __ ] time it's so long ago
now but every time we finish the podcast
i realized i forgot to bring it up and
that was when you and i went to the 7-11
oh yeah so i could get cigarettes and it
was [ __ ] weird it was that was so
strange
there was
so it was like there was a lady there
who stayed in the fridge
do you remember like this thing she was
just standing there yeah
it was the weirdest collection of people
doing stuff it was like the game
glitched and npcs were all [ __ ] doing
weird stuff right and it wasn't late
i think we was it was like eight o'clock
it was like eight o'clock yeah i just
went to get some cigarettes and um
and
there was a dude there who terrified me
and everything in my instincts like i'm
i'm i like i said i don't mind having a
bit of a fight but
i'm not an idiot i can look at someone
and be like nah he had like face tattoos
and was wearing one of these i'm not
having it i just was like in his but it
wasn't even like the tattoos you know
i'm not going to generalize it was just
the eyes and the gen i was just like oh
he's tasty nah i'm not doing it oh you
bowed out
what was he trying to [ __ ] with you for
he was doing this the whole time
there was a joke you confirmed like
while he was checking out he kept
turning around honestly
i just was a huge fan
it's like i know you loved eye zombies
no i i thought i thought it was more of
a super girl that's [ __ ] doctor
barney
chuckle barty
chuckle barty no he was and i pointed it
out to john because i didn't want any of
it i was just like no and also
i i would i was probably a little
i don't know
i try not to be larry in l.a because of
the guns in america
it's like scissor paper stone
yeah and i'm always just like knocked
down ginger exactly like it yeah um
but but yeah so anyway so this guy was
like kept looking at me and i was like
is this mistaken identity does he think
i'm someone else
um because it's hostile
and it's really [ __ ] intense and it
made me uncomfortable but whatever i
still stayed in line and waited and i
got served the dude left the 7-eleven
and as he left he walked out backwards
and
as he walked out the door backwards he's
doing this to me
right just staring at me like that and i
was like i don't want this and then once
he left i thought
okay
all right fine whatever just maybe he
was on drugs or something like that so i
buy my cigarettes and as i'm paying
doing putting my card through i look and
in the window
there are cardboard cutouts in the
display and between two heads he's there
outside the glass between the two heads
still [ __ ] looking at me pressed up
against the glass again john this is all
true that's real john
yeah
[ __ ] and i thought i was gonna get i was
like
i i don't know i just wanted to get out
of there yeah
i was like
again i don't think it was like he
watched
supergirl or some
one of my wonderful shows they're all
wonderful by the way fantastic did you
interact at all
no no not at all but um but i i
immediately i i always think stuff like
that's more like
maybe he thinks he's like we have i what
the worst my worst nightmare
the worst nightmare is is someone
who has a temper or might be armed
thinks i'm someone else and it's like yo
that's that dude that [ __ ] that dude
and i like brother you're sick before
they didn't like something in your show
like impossible all my shows are perfect
that is true yeah a lot of gays and lie
though
uh oh
what a gaze
a lot of staring a lot of gazing
oh gazing
yeah
people have problems with that you know
and
for you because you wrote it yeah uh so
after after we checked out we go outside
and we're walking back to the car and
rolls like
dude i feel is that guy like
gonna like come and get us or something
and then i looked back and i went there
he is and rahul
bolted for the car
that's not true i made that up
that's very weird i it was just intense
but it happened like it happened i think
yeah he thinks he stole his misses
it was my best guess
anybody else
what do you think it happened that's
right i think i think everything i mean
like i said i didn't like the i thought
that the look had bad intentions behind
it but then yeah you you know we've been
out and
i think pierce and i have spoken about
this like i do come from a bit more of a
like i don't know like in the uk in
london in particular like
you you avoid people it's like new york
city it's just you avoid right so any
type of interactions usually negative i
feel it's not positive it's usually like
you know so someone's looking at you
there's something's gone down or
something's about to go happen or
someone's going to say something with a
complaint and then i got to l.a you have
resting [ __ ] lips
yeah
the british version of wrestling [ __ ]
face yeah yeah
um but but it [ __ ] with me when i
first moved to los angeles um you know
i'd be in the elevator and someone would
just be like hey
good morning and i'd be like what's your
[ __ ] problem bro what the [ __ ] this
is peace are they is they got issues
i'm not joking i would be like what the
[ __ ] because i feel like that would be
passive aggressive in the uk like
oh did i do some did i step in dog [ __ ]
or am i standing again
polite yeah that's just like especially
in public transport and places like that
here it's not they mean it they
genuinely oh they got verbal diarrhoea
but they're like
they're just like hey
what you're carrying like seriously
people will ask you like if you're
carrying a gundam or a box you've got
shopping and they go
rx78 hey
somebody at pax there was i was in an
elevator with just me and this kid who i
don't know i'm really bad at guessing
kids ages would have been maybe 12. and
he was holding some pizza and i was like
nice and this is after a full three days
of not wanting to talk to anybody at all
ever like was very anti-social um
and i was like nice and
he was like oh thanks yeah i don't know
what the restaurant has so just got some
pizza and i was like they probably don't
have pizza you made the right call he
was like yeah it goes really well with
video games and i was like hell yeah
dude and it's like the best interaction
i've had with anyone in the last three
years just this little kid being like
yeah the pizza's gonna be sick let me
play fortnite with my friends and then i
just left and i was like all right i
spoke to a human and it was a 10 year
old kid and it was great i feel like
that'll happen in lines and stuff a lot
lately it's like just if you're in a
line you're waiting for a long time the
the person behind you the person in
front of you will end up interacting
with you and then you're kind of stuck
with that the whole
he was yeah kid just alone in an
elevator i think it's probably that i
wanted to make him comfortable because
he was like he was very young to be
fetching food alone
in a way that like if that were my kid i
would have gone with him he should have
just stared at what if he was 21 he just
got the age wrong
raphael i gotta cut you off real quick
that getting stuck in a conversation
thing
almost happened when we were in line at
the rin fair to get in this like
lady with a pink wig and her boyfriend
chimed in about oh it was about the star
wars yeah there was there was star wars
writing in the fake language on the back
of a car and i went jacob what is that
and he's like it's bugaboo
well it was worse because they were
talking about star wars first before you
asked me that so like we were both very
aware that they were talking about star
wars and you're like
jacob what's that language
i was like
i'm the arbish
um and then the girl and guy were like
oh my god you know what that is that's
crazy yeah and i was like yeah that is
crazy and then just turned my back to
them
and then we went on with our
conversation and they went on with
theirs wait was jacob stuck in the star
wars conversation though no no no no no
i got us out of it yeah that's good yeah
yeah it can be hard i i want to i want
to say
for any of the like i do bring a lot of
negative energy to the podcast and stuff
and and to be fair i will say that after
however many years i've lived here i
actually like it i i it's really it is
really nice like
i i kind of do wish
it's the sun maybe california i don't
know but it is nice to be in an elevator
and someone's just like
i now find myself having conversations
that across my day that are kind of
sweet and just very passing and it's
just like oh those are really nice
sneakers oh thanks oh you're a fan oh
cool oh liverpool yeah and it's just
like yeah i like it as long as they
leave
yeah yeah that's what i'm saying
elevator or something like i don't want
it
i don't want it at a restaurant i don't
want it you know i i don't mind it in a
shop but like i said when i went to the
warhammer cafe
uh just having those types of
conversations whereas in the uk it's not
we're a bit more quiet and and i
actually prefer it but back to that
7-eleven dude
oh no it wasn't seven i can't remember
where why i went on this tangent but um
yeah like i said someone oh that's what
i was saying alana and i
she's
when we've been out and stuff and uh
we get recognized either together
separately individually either one of us
we're never quite sure if it's as the
podcast or if it's for a lot of stuff we
have to wait for them and be like we
wait because we're like that person's
staring at us
and you're hoping that they'll use it
well they come up to you and they're
excited and you're like which one of us
are you excited about and
is it both of us yeah and then they
asked for a photo and you're like i
don't know if you know both of us
or they'll do this thing where like
they'll see alana and they'll go oh my
god alana pierce and they'll talk
and they're so like tunnel vision and
then maybe like 30 40 seconds later
after telling alan how much they love
her and what work they'll finally break
gays and they'll look up and go holy
[ __ ] because i'm taller than that
it also happens in japan town they were
like lawrence and then they were like
jacob
yeah
no no no that wasn't called they called
me john they did call you john
yeah
john right like nope
yeah
twice
but but also happened to be there i had
a weird interaction sorry rival if you
no no no
guy like saw me he's like oh hey are you
from uh you're from funhouse right i
remember you from like
years ago and like bruce and lawrence
were there and i was like oh yeah
coolest i can't take a picture with you
i don't know your name oh i was like
how do you know what i look like also
five years later say it just yeah just
act like you do and then he was like oh
it's like any is like other people from
that fun house here i'm like oh yes yeah
yeah like like a few of us always like
any originals like that
no he's doing his best he's excited but
damn it huts
i should have johnny you were right i
should have just told him that they were
in the
in the fair somewhere oh yeah
you should have been yeah you should go
find him
i think there's a
walled yeah no oh yeah i was saying to a
lot of the the the hostile part of me of
the what you're [ __ ] looking at
as someone who might now get recognized
it [ __ ] with my radar so someone's just
going
and i'll be at restaurant like brav and
it's like
they're like
i really like midnight mass
and it's like okay i'm sorry i saw i'm
not i'm not sufficiently famous enough
or use if you're dicaprio everyone's
gonna look you know it you know everyone
knows who you are yeah you are you're
sort of like
leonardo dicaprio yeah pretty cool yeah
yeah that's what i'm saying yeah yeah we
came out of everything everywhere all at
once and you were just like
oh my god
she's like oh yeah i like love your
stuff i got an acting because of you and
you were crying
amazing i tend to assume people are
staring at my hair
um
or something else i don't wishing people
know me so then
so then
naughty boy sneakers
i'll often get complimented on my sneaky
game by the way alana honestly swear to
god honestly just for a second just want
to say something just real quick if uh
john jacob or myself have said anything
to make you uncomfortable you can speak
to me i am the head of hr for idiots and
abroad so if there's anything you want
to say it's a safe space we will listen
we want you to be heard i think
i'm sorry about that
i've been uh
someone said i have huge flaps
um shut up who was telling a story get
back to the story
one of my favorite things is still
comment is saying alana was clearly
uncomfortable it's my favorite
like thank you for vouching for me i
appreciate that you guys have never made
me uncomfortable i don't want to put
words in your mouth but i would say that
us three are probably people that you're
some of the closest and most comfortable
with you're gonna be capable like it's
very difficult to make me uncomfortable
anyway i don't know that you could like
it would be so difficult to get but
i'm uncomfortable yep no i'm actually
very okay i take it back
the nudity is not the problem it was the
proximity
oh my god
is this okay as head of hr this is
problematic
the fact that ahead of hey did you see
alana's body language did you see how
her legs have cl like she had bundled up
she's just get on it
do you see look how afraid she is by the
way
i was on a podcast and then they have
like a separate
channel for their clips or something and
the most recent comment a few days ago
is someone going can't stand this guy
he's known he's a known misogynist about
me he's like i am
yeah in certain circles people can just
decide that ponytail clip
oh my god
the infamous [ __ ] elise bruce
ponytail that's right the thing that's
nice because how how much scrutiny that
got is that what elise did is really
funny oh yeah she gives her credit for
the good job
she made she made a good joke and gets
no credit for the joke that she made
itself yes the best thing about it is
people being woke
and not actually being woke enough which
is like they're like oh that's kind of
[ __ ] behavior from a guy to say that
it's like a context for anyone who
doesn't know
uh people at find out playing a video
game bruce made this comment about how
like no woman over a certain age should
have a ponytail and it's super
unattractive and elise is in the
background and she like pulls over and
starts playing with her ponytail
and grabs it and she goes to the camera
yeah
and obviously the whole thing's a joke
bruce isn't serious and bruce
keeps pushing the thing home while elise
is holding it and he's like
if you want to look like a woman
or something like that you don't bunch
it he was just going for it right and
he's not being serious and but at least
but what it did which was amazing so i'm
in the video james is in the video bruce
in the video and someone else is in the
video
and you were in that other person that's
incredible
huh
go ahead
someone else is there too
anyway
the four of us the four of us are in it
was the boyfriend some of you know the
originals yeah
but um
but the best thing about it was was that
because the daily mail
and buzzfeed whoever the [ __ ] drove all
these people over on facebook into this
comment section on youtube
um
in order to because it was like
awful men toxic men shame woman while
sitting there how embarrassing it meant
that we all and i got away with it a
little bit more than they did
got personally attacked for our looks
so savagely because they were trying to
protect the least yeah so people's
hairlines people's weight people's
jawlines people's features symmetry like
it was just being [ __ ] and then every
now and again someone would be like is
that [ __ ] doctor chakrabarty in the
sexist video laughing because half of my
face is like
when it's clipped
again the devastating part i don't give
a [ __ ] about the harassment you received
cry about it you big baby you know what
i'm saying is that elise didn't get
credit for the joke and i just
well that's what we all said we're just
like yo
elise is one off and we all agree
like one of the got one of the best
[ __ ] comedy brains period yeah um
one of my favorite things whenever we go
get dinner with her like watch her
freestyle
freestyling
good
her
it's wild it's not that good well john's
is better but
here goes give me some balls for a woman
does it look like my head's on backwards
it does a little bit yeah i don't like
it so death becomes her yeah a little
bit yeah oh my god your arms john did
your beard like make your neck burn like
sparse or something it's it like did
beards protect you from the sun yeah my
beard protected me so it's just like
right
that looks so raw yeah wow you just said
so like an australian you did the r
sure
god damn
um in miniature hobbies i made some
pre-orders today so i want to support
our community this is the last segment
of the podcast is
miniature can we do this every episode
and i know that like our audience is not
people who paints miniatures do they now
have a miniature um
segment it's the end of the show
what did rahul buy yeah that's a good
one i like that our first segment is
ending the show with what did rahul buy
i could cover that i'm down for that
segment let's go okay
is it today or since the last podcast
for sure if it's the last one guys you
take a while that's going to be an hour
no just keep it keep it uh concise just
this morning
yeah okay so just this morning i bought
let me show you so i i pre-ordered
masters of the universe battleground
it's only shipping in in the eu right
now
um but it's the masters of the home and
then oh no no no i found the us i found
someone in the us who oh
i mean this picture doesn't do it
justice but it's a master universe board
game
um and then i also purchased
um i pledged on kickstarter
to uh
marvel zombies
uh i got the devourer pledge so it's
um
every single
edition of this marvel board game where
every character is a zombie version of
it
it's [ __ ] cool man and then on top of
that i pre-ordered which jake would be
happy about uh i got the shadow
collective uh expansion to star wars
legion
um which is
cool oh man can i just can i send it in
chat then jacob can can actually see it
shadow collective that so i appreciated
this today from asmodi
uh legion star wars
legion
new
uh here you go jacob
uh it is
what is going on what are you [ __ ]
doing
what are you doing what are you doing
big comedy
oh god shadow collective here we are
here here jacob show me
sending you a link right now i would
like to know from the other pet owners
who have ever had a pet who's gone
through something like this
in the comments
is it just me or do every 10 minutes you
check to make sure they're still
breathing yeah i do that because i'm
like is he so pretty oh my god
amateurs
they go jake just put them on a rope out
back and then come back in three weeks
they
they can hang themselves oh cool
sorry i've covered up the entire chat
with that's fine star wars legion thing
whoa
oh and this is the black sun
yeah black sun yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
and this is the pledge
i got i got the i did the big pledge i
wanted to pledge all of it which was
like [ __ ] 800 bucks but all of it
oh my god
i have a name
that's that's chewbacca's son that's the
name of chewbacca oh he used to be
called lumper will rump
that's a good name
that wasn't the start with the holiday
special that's good i want to get this
pledge galactus pledge
[ __ ] cameo cameo if you can hear me
right now stop [ __ ] messaging me i
never want to [ __ ] join your app i'm
not charging to say hello to [ __ ] what
i do want though would be wonderful
if we could get more just send me free
miniature stuff and i'll keep plugging
them yeah um
i'm on cameo yeah
are you
yeah yeah that's all right i also
refused they they messaged me a lot and
i got pretty mad
they [ __ ] suck
look what i got
funerals yes oh baby yeah yeah my
favorite stack
well you only need i find with that one
oh jacob do you have the white one
right here okay because that's gonna be
your best friend afterwards that really
glosses up after um okay uh because you
if you're unpainting the gundams
do it where you go like up the
for gundam jacob you probably only need
to do
jacob for gotham you only need to do 800
1500 and then maybe finish with 2500. oh
yeah i've got them separate yeah
those are the you don't need to go lower
than 800 i think on on the gundam and
then switch to the to the buffing stick
at the end
yeah are you airbrushing
not yet i just need the paints and
i need to move my office around a little
bit
but i'm ready
too it's a windowless room
there's a window right there oh okay
that would be bad if it wasn't
when i was in eighth grade i uh was
building a model of a battleship and i
had the windows closed and i was using
model glue and then i was like i have a
headache and i feel like i can do
anything
this guy would be so bad to airbrush
jacob did you did you see the other link
oh another link hold on
really need to go to the bathroom you
guys
i need to not be in this sweaty dank ass
marvel zombies hold on i'm looking at
these undead pledge which pledge you do
the devour
guys we gotta you know devour
shut the [ __ ] up i'm [ __ ] talking
about miniatures you understand you
motherless [ __ ]
now we start
i mean
jacob
um thank you for watching everybody
we what what in the show keep you
updated on if we end up doing episode 12
live and only that would be dope um
we love you all thanks for watching
thanks for supporting us on patreon and
we'll see you next time
bye
bye oh he's really kissing that
you